[Music]  i  hate when i do that  keep an eye on me gambit you might learn  [Music]  this is the something christmas as an  x-man and we mean to make it  extra special it already is  observe first we  charge the queue maybe monsieur gambit's  not as good as he thinks he is  i must first find my sister and maybe  see more of america  after i fix your house  i never realized how much this dump  meant to me until somebody wiped it out  it will take time to put right what  sinister tried to destroy  thankfully the x-men have proved what  i'd always hoped  that in my absence they can carry on  together with our important work  after what we've been through lately i  figured we could use some time off  [Music]  what the heck destroy all mutants  with the friends of humanity who needs  enemies  [Music]  where's that blasted salami i can smell  it  ah all it needs is slicer  while you're at it fix one for me  [Music]  you